it's time now for the championship round
a possible five questions whoever comes
up with the most correct responses will
be the 2007 National Geographic Bee
champion I point out girl all right good
luck
what is the Arabic term for a valley in
the hot desert areas of northern Africa
and the Middle East that carries a
stream occasionally Arabic term put your
cards up each of you came up with the
same response of Wadi you are each
correct put your cards down here's your
next question
in late March 2007 Protestant and
Catholic political leaders from Northern
Ireland agreed to form a power-sharing
government that took effect in early May
of 2007 the leaders met in what city
that lies at the mouth of the login'
River put your cards up Belfast is
correct two points for each of you
question three the second largest oil
producer in sub-saharan Africa is also
the richest Portuguese speaking country
in Africa named this country
put your cards up you are both correct
with Angola three three the score
Lampedusa an island whose geographical
location has made it a target for
illegal immigrants seeking to enter the
European Union from Africa is
administered by which country Lampedusa
put your cards up Sunil has responded
with Spain Caitlyn has responded Italy
the country that administers Lampedusa
is Italy Kaitlyn leads four to three
which means that as we go to our fifth
question if she gets it right she wins
if Sunil makes a mistake even if Kaitlyn
makes a mistake also
she wins here's question five a city
that is divided by a river of the same
name was the imperial capital of Vietnam
for more than a century name this city
which is still an important cultural
center
put your cards up one of you is correct
Sunil you wrote down Ho Chi Minh City
and that is wrong way is right and that
means that Caitlyn staring
here at ten Sunil well done man
great